hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar using reference standards
to validate your NGS oncology workflow
presented by Hana child Diagnostics
product manager at horizon discovery and
I'm Whitney Jabari a Verizon discovery
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by horizon discovery before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like at any time during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and click on
the send button will save several
questions for Hannah to answer during
the Q&A session additionally we have
scientists standing by to answer
questions as they come up during the
presentation we'll answer as many
questions as we can if there are
questions that we don't get you will
send an email response in the coming
days additionally when this presentation
is available for on-demand viewing
questions can still be submitted and
they'll be they'll be routed to Hannah
and the research team for an email
response also please notice that you
will be viewing this presentation in the
slide window to enlarge this window
click on the two arrow symbol at the top
right-hand corner of the slide if you
have trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems through the ask a question box
continuing education credits are offered
for attending this webinar please click
on the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of this
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit also check
out the other tabs that contain helpful
resources that may answer questions that
will come up during this webinar
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
he a child will be taking us through the
tips and tricks learned through her
years of researching reference standards
gana join horizon as a product
development manager in 2016
working with the science has the
scientific research and development team
to develop new reference standards
before transitioning to the commercial
team as the Diagnostics make the
Diagnostics product manager and 2017
prior to joining horizon Hannah was
project manager for this shot kid I'm
sorry miss jot it stuck
nicely stratified medicine Scotland
Innovation Centre SMS IC and Glasgow
where she supported the establishment of
a new 8 sequencer ion proton NGS lab and
data centre and collaboration with a
thermo Fisher Scientific after
completing her PhD in molecular cell
biology in at Glasgow University hannah
worked as an analyst and then as a study
manager at bio outsource a Scottish CRO
specializing in immunotherapy screening
essays for biosimilar antibody
efficiency testing Hannah holds a prince
to practitioner certificate in project
management and obtained her via our BSC
hons degree and molecular biology from
Berg University now for the presentation
over to you Hannah thank you Whitney
we have three main learning objectives
for the webinar today firstly we hope to
help you learn some of the main criteria
to check when introducing a new NGS
assay into your lab testing menu this
includes criteria such as looking at
your accuracy and specificity the acid
limit of detection and how you may
handle challenging to sequence variants
like structural variants secondly we
hope you'll feel more confident to
recognize how to select the most
appropriate reference standard for your
acids
taking into consideration the allele
frequency the range of variant types you
should include the gene panel coverage
and the DNA format that will be most
commutable to your real samples finally
we hope to go through the best practices
for initial a/c validation and routine
quality monitoring including key
features such as robustness of your acid
user competency and how you may handle
your change control procedures
the majority of the restaurant standards
that we manufactured a horizon are aimed
at the NGS user group NGS done for
next-generation sequencing and the two
main providers of NGS platforms are at
alumina and Thermo Fisher Scientific
both companies offering multiple
different sequencing models here you can
see them displayed on the slide both
technologies offer sequencing by
synthesis with a luminous technology
being based on fluorescence and the
thermo Fisher Scientific Ion Torrent
technology being based on charge
you
you
though respective of whichever
sequencing platform your lab may be
using the same basic work for applies to
the majority of NGS clinical asses and
errors can be introduced at any stage of
the workflow this includes some of the
early steps such as extracting samples
from the patient's whether that be a
tissue biopsy settin FFPE or a blood
sample perhaps from liquid biopsy how
different labs handle the samples and
how they are processed in the early
stages can be very critical and we see
handling errors introduced at this early
stage
next you have extraction of your analyte
from the original sample whether your
analyte be RNA or more commonly DNA
and follow the extraction you'll want to
quantify and qualify your analyte and
there are many opportunities for arrow
to creep in at this early stage
following initial sample analysis the
analyte is prepped for the assay
which in the terms of NGS normally
includes library preparation and
templating and finally put on to one of
the sequencing workflows the last step
in the process is the bioinformatics
analysis and this can often be the most
complicated and error-prone in the
entire process with many different
settings and optimization options for
Aloud's to tackle and and is very
important to use reference standards to
make sure that this workflow with all
functioning correctly the end goal is to
be able to get the correct test result
back to the patient to go into the
problems around NGS a little little more
detail as mentioned the ideal final
output of NGS acid is a report listing
the true variants that are found on a
clinical sample however due to the
following technical issues this can
often be problematic for example the
sequencing platform itself can have
difficulties and physically
incorporating the correct base this can
be due to the natural error rate of DNA
polymerase or perhaps abscond drop out
due to poor a priori design of the gene
panel some DNA templates can also be
more difficult to sequence and this
includes CG rich regions or perhaps
hairpin loops which can inhibit the
activity of DNA polymerase and possibly
have unusual melting temperatures which
can affect sample preparation
additionally all the polymers can be
difficult for some platforms such as the
Ion Torrent platform which finds it
difficult to differentiate between an
accumulation of charges in long
stretches of homopolymers
we see the majority of clinical samples
coming from FFPE which is formula fixed
paraffin-embedded samples this is
because this type of sample preservation
technique was historically used for
microscopy
but due to the high abundance of samples
we now see this as the main input into
our clinical NGS labs well good for
microscopy the FFPE process causes
damage to the DNA that is very difficult
friends yes to handle in particular it
can cause d emanation of the DNA where C
and T can be mutated into T na bases and
this can cause artificial false positive
mutations to be called in your final
results which may not be a true result
of your patient's genetics you can see
on the right in a paper I highlighted
describing this issue of deamination in
more detail finally in relation to the
bioinformatics pipeline alignment of NGS
data to a reference genome can cause
multiple headaches for the analysis team
questions can be asked around which is
the most appropriate reference genome to
use and interestingly we see the field
possibly moving towards more intelligent
graft genomes than linear other
currently in use we see people becoming
more interested in sequencing tumor
normal matched pairs to identify somatic
mutations in cancer and also in
sequencing parent-offspring trios to
identify novel germline mutations where
these samples are available
the solution to controlling your error
rates in NGS is to use reference
standards to monitor every step of the
process a molecular essence standard is
a defined substance either DNA RNA or
protein which is used at a measurement
base of control for an assay Wrestle
standard should have a number of key
features which are essential to its use
it should be homogeneous and stable with
respect to a specified properties and
these properties can be qualitative such
as the absence or presence of a
particular variant and quantitative such
as the abundance of this variant within
the sample the reference standard should
be consistent and reproducible between
batches and possibly most importantly it
should be commutable which means that
issue closely mimic real clinical
samples finally reference standard
should be characterized using a number
of different procedures or by a
procedure considered to be the gold
standard and horizon we predominant
predominantly use digital PCR
had items referenced Anders have a
number of key features which makes them
a good choice friend yes web to use they
are cell line derived which means that
they closely mimic the patient genetics
and may be more appropriate for use as a
reference standard than perhaps some
synthetic plasmid alternatives this
means that the variants are presented in
the relevant genomic complexities we
have multiple sample formats available
by making real samples such as FFPE RNA
or formula and compromised DNA and
eraser standards are available at a
range of allele frequencies to best
match your needs
control are produced in a quality
controlled and validated environment and
prepared under a certified quality
management management system and we have
both ISO 9001 and a diesel one 3:45 in
place in our manufacturing facility in
the UK
horizons unique approach to
manufacturing reference standards stems
from our expertise in gene editing
technology as the schematic outlines we
begin with a wild-type cell line we
single-cell dilute that cell line to
produce a corner population
we then can perform precision gene
editing to create the clinically
relevant mutations that our customers
require and validate the final mutant
cell line
based on this technology we have a wide
range of materials available this slide
highlights some of the main categories
we have in particular is useful to point
out the cell-free DNA which is the
reference standard you would want to use
in the growing field of liquid biopsy we
also have multi-gene multiplexers for
larger gene paddle use and our largest
resin standard is called ultra span
which covers 150 to counter genes we
have single gene multiplexers if you're
running a particular bracket EGFR or
Kira switching panel RNA fusion
reference holders basic genome and a
bottle in FFPE and finally we have a
very experienced custom design team who
can help you if you need something a
little more of a spork
horizons rifle standards can be inserted
into an NGS work full at two different
points we have multiple formats
available to be incorporated at the
earlier stages of the workflow to test
the DNA extraction procedure others
includes our plasma cell free DNA
standards and our FFPE blocks
alternatively our cell free DNA and
buffer genomic DNA and four-wheelin
compromised DNA products can be inserted
directly into the library preparation
and should be handled in a similar way
to your other real samples
in this way reference standards are
suitable for three main applications we
see a lot of our customers using them
for a fee development to guide them as
they may be creating new gene paddles
athlete validation when people are
bringing in a new gene paddle into their
testing venue and routine laudatory
where labs they're continually using
reference standards on every rug to
provide evidence in order that their
quality procedures are after scratch
some of the main criteria to check when
introducing a new a C into your lab
testing menu are outlines in the seven
points below it's important to check the
accuracy of the specificity looking at
are the variants detected that are not
present and these are termed false
positives
what's the sensitivity of the assay
convenience be detected if they are
present what's the limit of detection
what is the minimum allele frequency
that can be detected and how does the
ASCII huddle structural variants how do
these difficult to sequence variants
perform on your workflow additionally
what is the repeatability is there any
run to run variability and
reproducibility can the results be
reproduced at perhaps different sites if
you might have a UK and a u.s. site is
interesting and important to compare
performance finally it's important to
check the robustness of your assay what
is the effect of sample quality on
performance
when using a reference them to control
for adder last a crap require a sample
with long sequence so this can be termed
in the field as a truth set looking at
accuracy specificity and sensitivity a
little more detail it's important to
test the ability to identify the correct
variants that are prep truly present
within a sample whilst minimizing the
level of both false positives and false
negatives false positives being the case
that you call a variant that is not
actually there and both negatives being
the case when you do not call a variant
that is actually there and both of these
outcomes can be very impactful to real
patient testing if they were to occur on
a real sample looking at sensitivity
it's critical to identify the asses
limited detection the
because councillor samples are
heterogeneous in nature and have a mixed
normal tumor cell population within one
sample as somatic variants that may be
driving that cancer could only be
present in a sub population of the tumor
cells
this means that labs want to be able to
know how low they can accurately call
variance and we see our equivocal lads
looking at around 5% allele frequency
if labs can call the reference standard
accurately yet for example two percent
variant allele frequency but it gives
them confidence and they can accurately
call rare variants in real samples as
low as 2% video to will frequency
as mentioned that's also becoming
increasingly important to understand how
your assay handles difficult sequence
variants this is becoming of increasing
importance as we gain knowledge about
more and more structural videos being
involved in driving cancer and more of
those structural variants are becoming
actionable with associated therapies
therefore is clinical oncology samples
are likely to contain these variants it
is important to validate the workflow
with reference standards that also
contain them
the types of variants that we're talking
about here are structural variants and
some of the main types to be listed
below this includes insertions and
deletions often termed in Dells copy
number variants terms CNVs or gene
amplifications gene fusions hula
polymers which are stretches of
repetitive sequence which can't be
challenging for some platforms and
high-low GC regions
interestingly clinical samples they
often contain perhaps only one or two of
these structural variants as a very
highly characterized level however one
of the main advantages of using
commercial reference standards is that
they have the ability to contain
multiple videos at once so you'll be
saving yourself time and money because
you'll also need to validate your assay
with one set of material
you
moving on to look at how you may select
the most appropriate reference standard
for your assay we're going to touch on
four main points the variant allele
frequency the range of variant types the
gene panel coverage and the DNA format
it's important to select reference
standard that contains variants present
a variant allele frequencies or var
calls to the intended limit of detection
option critical assay this table shows
some of the main multiplexes that we
provide here at horizon and the number
of variants that those products contain
within the three different bands at
litem table so it is out on the top row
our largest reference standard August
Babb contains 13 variants at between one
to ten a little frequency over 300
variants between 10 and 50 percent and
35 areas between 50 and 100 percent
alternatively are structural multiplex
record standard contains seven variants
all within the one to 10 percent bracket
multiplex standard contains variants at
both the 1 to 10
add the 10 to 50 percent brackets as
their their blackhat somatic multiplex 1
to point out our true q7 product here we
have 40 variants present at one point
three percent variant allele frequency
so this product would be very good for
labs here I really wanted to challenge
themselves and see if they could get
down to that very wool level of the real
frequency fundamentally a tuber is a
mass of cancer and non-cancer cells and
so therefore I've mentioned the council
would has expressed as a percentage the
allele frequency horizon reference
standards are able to mimic tumors by
combining normal our mutant cells
together to achieve the ratios outlined
to the previous products so we can
really create the other frequencies that
are required
this slide shows an example dataset of
how our multiplex one cell-free DNA
records data set may be used to help
calculate the limit of detection and 4th
positive error rates of an assay you can
see here that the reference standard
contains 8 different videos as the
product is available in four different
tubes with all the variants being
pressed about 5% 1% 0.1% and wild-type
in this example dataset you can see that
the lab was able to correctly call all
eight variants at the 1% a little
frequency but was not able to call them
at the 0.1% this informs the lab so
they're correct limited detection can be
considered as 1% and we'll frequency
interestingly this data set also points
out that the lab may be having problems
with the N R as a 59 T mutation and they
are possibly calling a false positive
here since they had opposed to reading
in the wild-type sample this type of use
of reference standards allows pipeline
optimization and provides confidence in
results when handling real patient
samples
to look at the second criteria it's
important to check the range of media
types in the reference standard and it's
good to select a reference standard that
contains video types that are likely to
appear in your clinical samples our
structural multiplex reference standard
contains a range of different mutation
types so we have copy number variants
fusion indels and variants present in
high and low GC regions you can see that
the structural multiplex reference
standard is available in three different
formats to best meet your needs at FFPE
genomic DNA has cell-free DNA
additionally our largest reference
standard olga's pan contains 30 indels
at is 2019 we're hoping to add more
structural videos to this large product
including coconut rebellions we also
have a range of RNA fusion reference
standards which are available at FFPE
these contain five quizzically valves
that are in ephesians have described to
the table below in alq red rose 1 and TR
q 1 and NTR key 3 if useful at this
product is also available with a batch
negative control and you'll feel the
right there that we had a very nice
white paper published in conjunction
with Thermo Fisher Scientific last year
where our are a future reference
standards were recommended for use
alongside their iron apathy and alkaline
ultra and ros1 fusions masses and you
can read more about that white paper on
our website
thirdly looking at gene panel coverage
you should select a reference standard
that contains variants that will
validate a large proportion of your gene
paddle and we see our user base moving
towards larger and larger gene paddles
as Merv alias become actionable for this
reason last year we launched our own
course by reference standard which
contains 386 millions across 152 old
coralv and genes and this product has
been validated by exome sequencing in
the table there you can see the G list
of the 152 genes that are covered in
this product
you
and the slide outlines how Olga's bad
can be used across different gene
paddles so we've done the comparison to
see what the gene coverage is like on
the main commercial gene panels and use
so to point out what aspect in
particular you'll see on the Illumina
true site trooper 170 gene paddle all
the span reference standard cover 74
genes within that paddle this allows
wider paddle validation that is possible
with most clinical samples which may
only contain a couple of variants in a
handful of genes by using Olga's band
you're able to validate a much larger
proportion of your gene paddle in a more
efficient manner
finally is important to look at the DNA
format of your record standard and to
select a reference standard that is
liberals commutable formats to your real
clinical samples at a high level all of
the horizon referenced adders are cell
ID derived which means that they're more
similar to real samples thousand
synthetic plasmid alternatives
at the deck level down all of our cell
line derive Breton standards are
available in multiple formats so we have
cell free DNA reference adders available
for liquid biopsy and the format of
these standards is flatbed to DNA with
the average fragment fragment length of
160 to 170 base pairs
in addition last year we launched some
of our cell free DNA reference standard
in that synthetic plasma which allows
labs to validate the early DNA
extraction step we also have FFP curls
for labs who are handling DNA from FFPE
samples and formula compromised DNA
referenced anders where the DNA has been
treated with formulas for different time
lengths to produce either mild moderate
or severe DNA damage with decreasing
bins as tested or the tape station the
formula compromised DNA reference
standards would probably be of more use
to labs who may be handling damaged DNA
but may not actually have extraction
facilities themselves where this last
year has delay the FFP curls would want
to opt for an FFPE vessel standard you
can see here the schematic some of the
main validation steps that we do for our
FFPE base standards are gel
electrophoresis and analysis or the tape
station
related to the topic of DNA format this
slide outlines some of the benefits of
using our synthetic plasma control we
see many disadvantages when using real
huber plasma such as variable quantity
and concentrations lot a lot variability
irregular supply contamination with
other a delights or genomic DNA and
cell-free DNA degradation where real
samples have time limited storage
as a solution to these problems we have
filed a synthetic plasma to be used as a
matrix for our cell free DNA reference
standard the advantages of this matrix
are that we have to find volume and
concentrations controls locked loss
stability and reliable supply no
interfering analytes or genomic DNA as
long-term stability of cell free DNA
beyond 24 months which is very important
reference standards as they may be
getting used over long time periods
across multiple labs in control studies
here we have some data from one of our
studies which shows the performance of
the synthetic class that compared to
Heba plasma and this data set really
gives confidence that the synthetic
class by matrix medics
Cuba plasma in terms of hybrid cell free
DNA we were able to recover during
extraction and in the detection of gene
copy number variance
the next part of the webinar will touch
on some best practices for the OGS
community some of the key features here
we're going to discuss our robustness
user competency and change control
we often get our customers coming to us
to ask about best practices and how they
should be using the reference standard
so it's really good to share some of the
tips and tricks and expertise that we've
amassed along the way
we find that use aggressive Thunder
supports our customers in their own
quality orders they may be going through
to achieve their ISIL or their CLIA lab
accreditation and some of the important
points to focus on are during initial
assay validation it's critical to check
acid robustness or different days with
different sample qualities and on
different sites if applicable
it's also important to assess user
competency and reference standards can
be used to ensure consistent accuracy of
results across multiple users this could
also be very beneficial to labs who
might have new staff to train and to
prove their competency during audit
where the results of how they sequence
the rest of standards can be kept to the
training file family it's very important
to monitor change control now we see
there's something we see this is one of
the main features that our customers
need support with where the best
practices to rub the rest that standard
on every sequencing run this helps labs
to monitor for change in accuracy over
time and some case studies that we've
seen crop up are that errors can be
introduced when new reagents are brought
in to work full
and perhaps to qualify a new version
releases of analysis software so for
some of the buyers romatic software our
customers may be handling multiple
version releases per year and this could
be a dangerous area of error
introduction so running a reference
standard on every run allows them to
flag up and notice any change in
accuracy with these change in reagents
and software finally labs are often
subject to changes in location where
equipment needs to be moved between labs
or even to new buildings and the
recalibrations that to make sure the
equipment is performing as it was before
is essential and run in reference
standards before and after the move can
help to confirm this
finally I have included some screenshots
of some of the best guidelines that are
currently available for NGS labs here we
can see an article that was published in
2017 called guidelines for validation of
next-generation sequencing based on
ecology panels and this is sort of the
latest recommendations from the College
of American Pathologists
secondly we see a lot of our users
relying upon the New York state
guidelines and here we have a
publication from them in 2016
called next generation sequencing
guidelines for somatic genetic variant
detection now this remains one of the
gold standard guidelines in place today
for NGS labs sadly there was an
interesting paper that came out last
year in Nature Reviews
called reference standards for
next-generation sequencing by Hardwick
at all and as highlighted of the
abstract here they concluded that the
errors associated with a GS can be
understood and mitigated through the use
of reference standards so to finish I've
included some links to helpful resources
here the top link is a link to our
website for more information or the
reference standards described in this
presentation we also have an excellent
application where you could read more
about technical information
but by the way I've posted links there
to the three guidelines that were
described to this presentation the cat
sidelights new york state guidelines add
the nature review paper
I'd like to thank you for your time the
Ted ship and pass over to Whitney to
handle any questions Wow thank you so
much Anna for this informative
presentation we'll now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar now while
we're getting ready for the Q&A session
two polling questions will appear on
your screen we really appreciate your
answers to these questions so we can
follow up with you appropriately I'd
like to remind our audience that you can
submit questions by typing them into the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen just type your
question into the box and hit Send will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for okay Hannah are you ready
for some questions yes I'm ready awesome
okay so the first question in the queue
is what are the advantages of clinical
oncology testing by liquid biopsy as
opposed to from sspe
thank you that's a good question I think
one of the main advantages we're seeing
in the field is that it really holds a
lot of promise to make testing more
accessible and easier for the patient
which is hugely important
so when collisions are obtaining samples
to be used to the FFPE workflow the
patient has to go through a surgical
procedure to obtain that biopsy sample
with is the new field of liquid biopsy
allows the DNA to be collected from a
simple blood draw from the arm so in
much less invasive for the patient and
also it means that due to the increased
accessibility of DNA it opens up new
doors to routine monitoring and
increased testing for the patient over
time perhaps to look at changes to
therapy to sports and also to monitor
how their cancer may progress long term
that does seem like that makes a big
difference
Wow okay great I have another question
here the second question is do you offer
Conners bein in any other format
okay currently our uncle spam product
which we launched last year were
launched in G DNA ugly however we have
had lots more custom requests to provide
this large reference standard and cell
free DNA for that so that's definitely
something that is available through our
custom team at the moment and we are
launching August and in FFPE next year
and it's most likely that cell free DNA
version will follow due to the high
demand Wow okay here I'll choose another
one okay so this question is they want
to know Hannah is it possible to make a
bespoke blend and I'm not even sure if
I'm pronouncing that work backwards
right hopefully is read a different
allele frequency a bespoke blend yes so
in our off-the-shelf catalog we have
over a hundred record standards with the
ll frequencies determined and qualified
for every batch and many we touched upon
today however some of our customers may
need something a little different and if
you required a little frequency or even
additional variants that we don't cover
in our catalog we have a really
experienced and excellent custom design
team who can make you something with the
specialist requirements that you may
need
so yes changes to the old frequency and
also to the videos included in the
reference standard is possible and we do
process a lot of projects like that day
to day
Wow so customization to the max that's
really cool yes that is awesome
i cool so there's a few more questions
that are coming in that check the time
oh we're doing good okay
so here's another question it is it
possible to extract those DNA and RNA
from the RNA reference standards
yet another good question we have had
some interest about the past and the
early reference standards are sold as an
FFPE curl including the cell lines that
contain those fusions so out Gretsch
rows one NTR key one and Antioch III we
only validate the reference standards
and those futures at the RNA level
however there's the reason that
customers can also extract the DNA from
the curl to the cell ends are there and
we actually did a technical study on
this and have an app note available on
our website describing how customers
could perform dual extraction of both
DNA and RNA from the RNA reference
standard curls if they desire to do that
so have a read of the app note that we
recommend which extraction kit we used
but keep in mind that we will be
validating the fusions at the level of
RNA so far okay and to know okay so does
look like we're approaching the end of
our trans lie but we've got time for
just a very last question let's see it
says do you have any reference standards
for microsatellite instability
yeah we're seeing microsatellite
instability as a growing area and we've
had a lot of requests from our customers
for this I think we'll see increased
testing added increased need for effort
started there currently we don't have
one available in our catalog but we're
planning to launch one at the beginning
of next year so it's quite exciting it's
one of our most interesting R&D projects
at the little bit so we do have some
material that we're testing it has and
hopefully that new FSR is started will
be coming to market early next year
while exciting times and the field of
cosine well and I thank you so much for
being here and sharing this great
information with us and for the audience
thank you so much for your participation
that you guys are really what makes this
webinar so interactive and so fun for
all of us and thank you again just for
all your questions I see that there are
a few more questions remaining in the
queue
if your questions were not answered one
of our scientists will respond to you
via email if you have further questions
but did not get submitted during the
broadcast please email them at une info
at horizon discovery.com
all right before we go we would like to
thank both laberd's and horizon
discovery for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through January 2019
lathers roles are via email when it's
available to replay on demand we
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues who may have not been
able to attend today right but an exit
poll will come up on your screen please
please please please share your feedback
with us it'll help us plan for all
future webinars until next time we'll
see you soon goodbye